Pokemon Sun and Moon is introducing a  ton of new Pokemon but it's also putting  new twists on the classics I'm Tony and  this is your tropical gamespot news  update several of the original 151  Pokemon can be found in the lolla region  but they've taken on new forms executor  looks even more like a palm tree now and  vulpix in San true along with their  evolved forms nine tails and sand / our  ice types on top of that each pokemon  type has an uzi move which can be used  once per battle moves like Inferno  overdrive and hydro vortex sound  incredibly powerful the alittle region  really seems to be taken quite a few  steps forward for the Pokemon series  Pokemon Sun and Moon launches on  November eighteenth until then you can  expect plenty more information about the  game trailers have already teased new  Pokemon island challenges and so much  more to keep up with all the pokemon  news you're already in the right place  you